I gather your question is wow how did
this happen so there were there were
three there were several ingredients
okay one ingredient was there was a
bubble in housing prices people assume
that housing prices would just continue
to go up and up and up and that they
could take on unrealistic amounts of
debt because the appreciation and the
value of their houses would make it
possible for them to deal with that
amount of debt the other thing that
happened was that there was a breakdown
in lending practices by mortgage lenders
so there was not sufficient oversight
the fee structure for for mortgage for
people issuing mortgages with such that
their only incentives were to get
mortgages out there to grant them and
then the other ingredient was sort of
the rapid securitization of lending
throughout the economy throughout the
world so what happened is these
mortgages got bundled and sliced into
different pieces that supposedly
represented different risk
characteristics and then there's the
vast machinery of the securitization
industry which rated a lot of these
things as Triple A or you know very very
safe securities when they in fact were
not and so there was a hole under chol
of things that that that resulted from
this that meant housing prices began to
fall this whole this whole business
collapse and that and that caused panic
and essentially in the credit markets
because many people found themselves
holding these exotic securities that
were
were dependent that were these bundled
mortgages or pieces of them that they
could not sell